Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Le bois est un matériau indispensable
pour décarboner le BTP.
Je vous ai apporté
cet échantillon de bois d’ossature
qui permet de construire mieux
et avec moins d’énergie.
Imaginez : une tonne de bois mis en œuvre,
c’est l’équivalent de 1850 kilos
de CO2 capté, stocké, capturé.
C'est ce qu'on appelle
un puits de carbone.
Le bois est une ressource précieuse.
C'est un matériau idéal.
Vous pouvez l’applaudir.
(Applaudissements)
Ha ! Attendez.
Il me semble qu'il a quand même un défaut.
Il ne parle pas.
A-t-il fait deux fois le tour de la Terre
pour être transformé
et venir jusqu’à nous ?
Ou provient-il de la forêt d’à côté
pour ensuite être transformé
dans une scierie locale ?
Difficile de le savoir.
De quelle forêt ?
Qui l'a transformé ?
Combien de kilomètres a-t-il parcourus ?
C’est là que l’innovation
numérique intervient
pour nous aider à faire les bons choix.
Je travaille pour une association
qui fédère des acteurs de la filière bois
à l’échelle du Massif central.
Dans ce cadre, nous développons une
application qui permet de tracer le bois
de la forêt jusqu'au bâtiment.
Cette application nous informe
précisément sur l’origine du bois,
sur qui l’a transformé.
Cette chaîne de traçabilité
est garantie à 100%,
grâce à la certification
« Bois des territoires du Massif central »
mise en place il y a cinq ans.
Ce bois, nous allons le faire parler.
Je vous donne cet exemple.
Un chantier - un gymnase -
qui est en cours de réalisation,
mobilise 170 mètres cubes de
bois technique de grande portée.
Grâce à l’engagement des acteurs
de cette filière,
vous avez une information précise
sur l’origine des bois mis en œuvre.
Nous savons aujourd’hui qu’en France,
une majorité des bâtiments publics sont
construits avec des bois d’importation
qui ont fait certainement
des milliers de kilomètres.
Cet exemple
nous montre que construire
autrement, c’est possible.
Relocaliser la ressource
et sa transformation
est un enjeu essentiel pour lutter
contre le changement climatique
et favoriser l’activité
dans nos territoires.
Nous devons construire
moins, mais mieux,
rénover massivement avec
des matériaux biosourcés et locaux.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)